with thanksgiving marking the official
beginning of holiday season we check in
with don mccarthy beauty and lifestyle
advisor of dawn's corner to give us a
sneak peek into some great gift ideas
for everyone in the family for this
year's holidays hi las vegas what says
happy holidays more than a board game
played with family and friends author of
rich dad poor dad robert kiyosaki
creates board games for family fun and
financial education
cash flow for kids is one of the safest
ways to teach kids valuable life lessons
without actually taking the risk playing
this game and simulation will enable
your children to develop good behavior
which will help them not just survive
and escape the rat race but actually
create smart money habits they'll use
later in life order yours today at
richdad.com
for the beauty lovers this choco hug kit
by everyday for future contains a face
mask and a face cream for under 10 bucks
making it a great go-to gift for any
friend or family member both products
have powerful antioxidant properties
orange essential oil and cacao butter it
smells delicious the face mask has up to
12 uses and the face cream has up to 40
uses in this single pouch they have a
ton of great holiday options so check
them out at everydayfutureusa.com
now have you ever noticed when you give
your dog a new treat you always smell it
first me too
when they started creating this dog line
at crown to tail the treats had to be so
tasty that pups would have to hide them
from their human
using the highest quality natural
ingredients you won't find any
preservatives in these tasty snacks that
are made right here in the usa once you
smell them you're definitely going to
want to try them for yourself their
limited edition christmas breakfast
flavor will be a perfect santa pause
treat go to crowndetail.com to order
some for your fur kid today next i have
two adorable children's books that are a
part of the popular rambi boo series in
rambi boo's snowed in two a big
snowstorm has rambi boo and his friends
divided while rock loves to play in the
snow rambi boo sits by the window
worried about freezing his paws the
readers will find out if rock can think
of a clever way to get rambi boo to join
in the winter fun in rambi boo and the
christmas sock the rambi boo friends are
decorating for christmas when they
discover that rambi boo's favorite sock
is missing readers will join in on rambi
boo and rock's special christmas story
filled with love and the magic during
the holidays this award-winning series
feature themes such as problem solving
teamwork patience and addressing anxiety
kids can have their own comfort sock
like rambi boo to provide emotional
comfort and support go to womanbooks.com
to order today looking for something
special for the beauty brush fan lexi
takes the guesswork out of gift giving
with these curated sets featuring some
of luxie's best-selling vegan high
performance makeup brushes the golden
glow set in stardust set includes a set
of glimmering brushes needed to create a
full face look these brushes feature
easy to grip handles and are stored in a
sophisticated brush holder that adds
elegance to any vanity the skin
essential skin care set is a six piece
set that helps evenly apply gels creams
serums and more with these brushes that
absorb little to no product letting
nothing go to waste the getaway travel
set features four makeup brushes and a
sponge in this stylish pouch and lastly
the brow set features essential tools
needed to sculpt fill and style your
best brows go to luxiebeauty.com to
purchase any of these sets
now for more information on any of these
products visit dawnscorner.com
see you next month